it's a tax paradise with special offers  the grand duchy of luxembourg some  corporations allegedly paid less than  one percent tax on their profits through  complex financial structures and the  help of luxembourg authorities  implicated german firms include deutsche  bank and energy group e on the companies  say they always acted lawfully he kept  ok I have no understanding for that not  everything that's lawful is also  legitimate big companies have social  responsibilities salif and fought the  allegations stretch from 2008 to 2010  that was when jean-claude juncker was  Luxembourg's prime minister he became  head of the European Commission just a  few days ago the very institution that  now has to investigate the matter